(bassy hip hop)
- We're here with pro gamer
Mike Chaves, what's up man.
- Member of the top three
ranked Halo team in the world.
- Our goal here today is to beat him,
and become the number two ranked team.
That's how it works, right?
We beat you, we become number three?
- Yeah, once you beat me.
- So you ready to get your ass kicked?
- I don't think it's gonna happen.
- How do you play Halo again?
- I'm at the bottom right.
Tryna kill Mike at the top.
- I'm just so terrified right now.
I'm playing mostly with fear.
- Wait, wait, wait!
- I'm getting killed.
Fuck.
- Fuck, man!
(laughter)
Yo Mike, quick question, man.
How do you like become
a professional gamer?
You gotta put hours into
the game basically and just.
- How many ways can you kill a person?
- All right, I'm about to kill you.
- I'm asking you for
advice, you gon kill me
right in front of my peers?
(laughter)
- Why you killing us so quickly man?
How that happen?
- I'm not gonna die anymore.
Sick of dying.
Fucking Christ, man.
- [Game] Untouchable! Game over.
- Yo I think this game is racially biased.
(bassy hip hop)
- You know what, I think
I'm gonna get some lunch.
- Go get some lunch, man.
- [Keith] Chinese.
- All right, cool.
(trippy music)
- Yo, you wanna get General Tso's?
- Nah man, I think I'm gonna
do something different.
(slow mo) Something different.
(words echo) General Tso's?
- Come on, dude.
(slow mo) Come on, dude.
(trippy music)
(words echo) General Tso's?
- Uh, hello.
- Hi, can I get General Tso's?
(sleazy beat)